[Música]
bienvenidos a la entrevista en france 24
mi invitado es rafael grossi director
general del organismo internacional de
energía atómica buenos días muchas
gracias por estar con nosotros en france
24 gracias a ustedes ha pasado seis
meses desde que rusia invadió a ucrania
y la situación en torno a la central
eléctrica de sap orilla la mayor de
europa preocupa especialmente a la
comunidad internacional usted mismo
rafael grossi lamentó los nuevos
atentados de los últimos días alrededor
de esta central en primer lugar cuáles
son los riesgos de un accidente nuclear
los riesgos son reales
y la cuestión
como usted lo dijo es una instalación
importante es la mayor central nuclear
de europa que está ocupada por fuerzas
rusas a veces y que es operada por
operadores ucranianos por lo que ya es
una situación sin precedentes y
complicidad
y ha habido ataques ha habido bombardeos
sabemos quién está detrás de estos
ataques porque los rusos y los
ucranianos se están culpando los unos a
los otros exactamente hay una narrativa
contradictoria y esa es una de las cosas
que deberíamos ser capaces de establecer
claramente terno amplio y sexy además
siempre existe la posibilidad de que se
interrumpa el suministro de energía a la
planta eléctrica
lo que podría provocar la interrupción
del sistema de enfriamiento de la
central
nacional los rusos harían eso es decir
se interrumpirían eventualmente su uso
no puedo juzgar sus intenciones esta
central es eso lo que dicen los
operadores ucranianos es posible no
puedo excluirlo pero como usted dice hay
acusaciones mútuas que se cruzan y de la
unicit y de ahí la necesidad de la
presencia del inspector nuclear mundial
que es el organismo y el organismo el
organismo que usted dirige rafael grossi
este jueves se reunió con el manuela con
francia apoya esta iniciativa
el envío de una misión del organismo a
las zonas se enviará realmente una
misión de este tipo a favor y ya estamos
trabajando creo que es posible para el
presidente marco no es una cuestión de
la última semana sino desde marzo por lo
que estoy en contacto con el banco y la
sangre
ha entendido lo que está en juego en el
plano nuclear de este conflicto pero es
complejo está la cuestión del territorio
como lo hacemos por donde pasamos no es
fácil y la situación se ha deteriorado
con el paso del tiempo
se ha deteriorado las operaciones
militares se han agudizado la central o
los emplazamientos se han convertido en
un objetivo ilícito de vías y que no se
salva de los ataques militares a novio
jake y ni para españa realiza esto es
totalmente inaceptable es inquietud
inaceptable doc la manera de estabilizar
es tener una presencia internacional
allá se daba a la prestancia nacional
soplas y el presidente marco ha estado
en contacto con el presidente selenski y
con él putin conmigo incluso hemos
tratado de encontrar el mínimo político
para comenzar con la parte técnica
existe hoy un acuerdo entre los rusos
los ucranianos francia posiblemente y
otras partes para enviar esta misión hay
acuerdos sobre los principios estoy
trabajando en los detalles
los detalles
tiene una posible fecha en la que esta
misión sería enviada allá tenemos
hipótesis de trabajo y ocurrirá muy
pronto que se lo aseguro muy pronto
quiero decir semanas en pocos días así
que en pocos días se podría enviar una
misión del oiea las aporías y quien
bloquea hoy en día nadie más los rusos
creo que ya no hay bloqueo hay dudas
y había objeciones a nivel de un lado y
del otro político
ahora hemos llegado a una etapa y yo voy
a insistir demasiado en esto existe la
suite y para no arruinar la posibilidad
de éxito ni la posibilidad de un
suicidio pero creo que estamos muy muy
cerca de la aceptación total y completa
por ambas partes y porque aceptaría de
repente cuando antes se negaron creo que
todos se entendieron hace unos días hice
un informe ante el consejo de seguridad
de las naciones unidas los 15 miembros
más ucrania hay enormes diferencias
políticas como se puede pensar pero
todos dijeron una cosa el organismo debe
ir tú todos ven que hemos llegado a un
punto en el que no podemos arriesgarnos
a un accidente nuclear además del drama
de la guerra así que los rusos estarían
finalmente convencidos de dejar los
italianos que también se oponían al
principio todo el mundo está a favor era
una cuestión de perseverancia cuando
hablaba de los detalles cómo puede
funcionar esta misión en un país en
guerra
lo haremos un poco más voy a liberar
esta misión con mis expertos técnicos de
admisión además experto nik vamos a
hacer un balance de la situación vamos a
hacer reparaciones vamos a restablecer
los sistemas de transmisión de
información que resultaron afectados y
que usted tanto más allí y luego
probablemente vamos a asegurar una
presencia continua del organismo
es una tarea enorme y esperamos que
ayude a estabilizar la situación la
situación los granos especialmente en el
guatón agencia que gestiona esta central
acusar a los rusos de almacenar armas
pesadas es eso lo que está pasando
déjenme ir a ver qué encontramos pero ha
escuchado estos comentarios del lado
ucraniano lo hemos oído pero poco hemos
hablado de corroborarlo así que la idea
es ir y verlo usted mismo exactamente
realmente los rusos quieren desconectar
la central nuclear de la red eléctrica y
desviar la a crimea hay información al
respecto
no es algo fácil de hacer no es sólo
conectar y desconectar la gameplay y la
central eléctrica para desconectar la de
una red de un grito como se dice en
inglés de una red eléctrica y para
desconectar la de la otra no es cosa de
los días hay obras de infraestructura
eso lo he oído de nuevo esa es una de
mis tareas
ver lo que está ocurriendo constata
constatar si es cierto o no y entonces
una vez que se constante que sigue
hacemos un informe tendremos
recomendaciones y se las comunicaremos a
los gobernadores del organismo y a la
comunidad internacional y esperamos que
las partes hagan seguimiento
en cualquier caso es optimista en
cualquier caso toca hacerlo otra crisis
que él concierne directamente es la de
las negociaciones nucleares iraníes
estas negociaciones se habían suspendido
y se reanudaron a principios de agosto
eeuu había indicado que ya había hecho
concesiones en una serie de puntos clave
el ministerio de asuntos exteriores
iraní ha señalado que recibió una
respuesta de eeuu podría haber un
acuerdo finalmente eso parece eso parece
tuvimos momentos así tuvimos momentos
menos optimistas creo que no estamos
lejos de a qué se refiere cuando dice
que no están lejos todos los aspectos
técnicos están más o menos resueltos es
una cuestión de voluntad política y no
ha sido una cuestión de voluntad
política también había problemas a nivel
técnico
y exigieron al organismo que dejara de
investigar los lugares no declarados en
los que se habían encontrado restos de
uranio enriquecido se retractaron de
esta condición los iraníes hay
declaraciones al respecto a la
declaración
lo único que puedo decir es que en
nosotros no dejamos de trabajar por
razones políticas harry potter es un
político nuestro organismo debe llevar a
cabo su trabajo un trabajo y la he
invitado y sigo insistiendo en que
debemos trabajar de forma cooperativa
con irán para aclarar este afán de
clarifica esas cosas no van a
desaparecer cuando dice esas cosas a qué
se refieren con las dudas que tenemos y
los temas que tenemos que aclarar el
hecho de que haya restos de uranio
enriquecido etcétera lo que usted
menciona y así que lo que hay que hacer
es sentarse y tratar seriamente de
aclarar todos los aspectos
y esas pilas los estadounidenses parecen
decir que hoy estamos más cerca de un
acuerdo que hace unas semanas hay un
poco de optimismo no voy a hablar en
nombre de eeuu voy a decir que el
organismo está ahí está listo puedo
proporcionar las garantías e
inspecciones para este acuerdo con este
uranio enriquecido será capacidad de
pasar fácilmente a la fabricación de la
bomba sí pero el hecho de tener material
no significa que se vaya a pasar
directamente a las armas nucleares no
sería justo decir eso fonsi
meses pero es así ya no hay información
que indique que irán tenga un programa
de este tipo
pero hay varios think tanks que lo dicen
que son especializados ese es el trabajo
de los think tanks el mío es
inspeccionar usted de inspección existe
alguna condición en la que los
estadounidenses e iraníes se habrían
retractado vuelvo a este punto
precisamente porque este acuerdo sería
firmado finalmente mientras que hace dos
meses se decía que había expirado el
problema es que a medida que pasa el
tiempo se añaden problemas se establecen
vínculos entre cosas que no está
necesariamente relacionadas con
cuestiones nucleares y no para quienes a
veces sanciones económicas a veces con
otras cuestiones ya o políticas y eso lo
complica
de ahí la urgencia de alcanzar el
acuerdo cuando las condiciones políticas
son ideales y cuáles serían las
condiciones políticas ideales al final
esto se trata de preguntarse si se
estará mejor es conseguir con este
acuerdo o sin él israel piensa por
ejemplo que se está mejor sin este
acuerdo esa es la opinión de israel y
los iraníes y los estadounidenses por
otro lado podrían continuar su europeos
obviamente están a favor completamente
la carta europea permitió avanzar en las
últimas semanas el papel de la unión
europea ha sido crucial en qué medida en
la medida en que esta negociación fue la
unión europea la que hizo la
coordinación y así la coordinación
creo que hizo un muy buen trabajo al no
rendirse nunca me desesperaba al
insistir siempre en llegar al momento
en que se alinearán las estrellas por
así decirlo felicito al seniat y se
dieran las condiciones políticas para
alcanzar esta cuerda y de asetac o
cuando pensaríamos que este acuerdo ha
caducado usted no cree que así sea lo
que se llama el jc pero por el momento
no tenemos el gp oa una incógnita
tenemos una cáscara vacía vivir en la
idea es revivir la
llenarla de contenido
conoce a conseguir que irán empieza a
cumplir a que empieza a cumplir todas
las obligaciones que quedaron
incumplidas efe acuse por la retirada
unilateral de eeuu en su momento de
visitas venía lippok y los iraníes son
más cooperativos actualmente
están a la espera creo de la renovación
de este acuerdo que por el momento se
encuentra en un punto muerto porque no
mandan a paz muchas gracias por estar
con nosotros una fadel rossi director
general del organismo internacional de
la energía atómica y gracias a todos por
ver este programa exclusivo sigan con
nosotros en france 24
[Música]